Putin does not have enough newcomer for all the
dissidents because after the start of
the war, many people began to speak
words against this war and against the
criminal military regime. Putin,
of course,
protest from below is now impossible
because the security forces are everywhere almost
3 million people serve the
FSB police other structures, this is still  not
counting all the private security there.
Therefore, I would not now hope for a
protest from below, because it is practically
in the history of Russia that Stalin's times have come,
everyone is afraid from below, because there
is not even a leader who is able to
organize this Navalny in prison,
the rest of the leaders are abroad on the
territory of Russia  not a single
active opposition force that
could consolidate at least this
protest. Therefore, in this case, we
can only talk about a split in the Elite, saying
this does not mean that it will be some kind of
conspiracy there with the murder and poisoning of the
dictator, maybe someone will come to
Putin and say  Volodya will hint to him,
the war is lost, you are already tired, go away, let's
change something else, start now. It's just that
people will tear